Why is endemia common with cancer?
So, endemia, and remember, there's multiple different types of endemia, and I have a blog post on all those different types of endemia.
There's iron deficiency, endemia, P12,
endemia, P6, deficiency, endemia, folate, deficiency, endemia, and the most common,
there's one that's actually called endemia of chronic disease, that is, well, cancer falls into it, but it is an iron deficiency of review.
And there are certain characteristics of each one of those endemias.
So, when we look at endemia, we don't just look at your total red blood cell, we look at hematocurid, hemoglobin,
um, uh, HCV, you know, a bunch of different factors in there when we look at your CBC with differential.
So, um, why is it common with cancer?
Because some cancers can double upired, that's another one reason.
It's common with cancers, if it's an abdominal cancer, you could have a bleeding issue that could cause it.
So, even if you don't have cancer, a bleeding issue is the first thing you want to look at it, of course, it has iron deficiency.
But it's typically common with cancer, because cancer can double upired.
And then when you give iron to a cancer patient, you want to always couple that with a lead with, um,
artimicidid, because artimicidid tends to follow iron.
So, it'll actually be just drawing iron, drawing artimicidid into the cancer cell.
So, you want to be careful.
You don't want to just throw iron at a cancer patient because potentially you're basically, you know, possibly beating the cancer by giving iron when iron is being dabbled up by the cancer.
So it makes sense to be careful, um, but you get to this point where you, I didn't catch 22 or you have to treat the ademia.
Well, the person that's mild anemia with cancer, I typically do not jump right at giving iron, um, because of the fact that the cancer is already thought to lead it out that you don't want to just feed it.